[Musique]
1831 je Jean-Pierre François Nicole
robinet de la serve a marqué l'histoire
politique de la Réunion son mausolée se
trouve aujourd'hui au cimetière de
Saint-André né en
1791 à Bourbon il en part après la prise
de lîle par les Britanniques en 1810
journaliste puis avocat de retour dans
lîle il est à l'initiative du mouvement
des franc
créoles cette société secrète composé de
petits et moyens planteurs s'oppose au
gouverneur en effet alors que les
tentatives d'absolutisme monarchique en
France ont été balayés par la Révolution
de 1830 le chef de la colonie qui
gouverne seul avec les plus grandes
familles comme les débassin rechigne a
accordé des
libertés les franc créol s'appuient sur
un journal clandestin le salasien pour
réveiller l'opinion publique et faire
prendre conscience au colon de la
nécessité de participer à la vie
politique ces libéraux n'arrivent pas à
avoir la majorité face aux conservateurs
mais ils ont finalement gain de cause en
1833 avec l'élection d'un conseil
colonial si robinet de la Serve est
favorable à l'abolition de l'esclavage
tel n'était cependant pas le cas de la
grande majorité des Fran
[Musique]
1831 les Francs
créoles